bring in Chris Mannix he's senior and be
a writer from Sports Illustrated is it
different Chris that we how we look at
Kauai if he joins the Lakers and makes
them a super team as opposed to Kevin
Durant joining Golden State I think it's
different because of the circumstances I
mean Kevin Durant rejoined Gold mistake
was just beaten by Golden State if you
know if the Lakers had knocked off the
Raptors in the finals and Kauai jumped I
think we probably have a different
opinion of this possibility but if he's
doing the Lakers I just think people
will say wanted to go back to Southern
California and the Lakers you know I
guess offer the best chance to win even
though I'm not I'm not entirely
convinced of that Dan I mean I keep
hearing this narrative that yeah they
would be a super team no question with
the three guys but I know that they'd be
the favorite next year I mean you have
to fill out that roster somehow and it's
it's not three on five or three on seven
or eight and you look at teams that are
are deep in that way I mean yeah I just
think the first year they certainly have
some trouble winning if go I want up
there what is the holdup here what is
Kauai waiting for I don't know what he's
waiting for anything you know it like
everybody else
it's been tough to get any kind of
information out of out of both his camp
and you know the people inside the other
organizations because there's so much at
stake for for all three of these teams
that that nobody's trying to tip any
hand one way or the other I just think
why in his first you know foray into
real free agency with with a lot more
than just you know where he wants to
play and the type of players he wants to
play with at stake remember the medical
stuff really matters to Kawhi Leonard I
mean the Raptors did a great job last
year of you know kind of patching them
together for that 60 regular season
games in the final 24 the playoffs and
even at the end then he was battling
through something and he made it all the
way to the final so yeah I think Kauai
and the people around him are doing a
lottery
search on on on just what kind of
programs these teams can put on this is
why this is why the Raptors you know I
don't want to say feel confident but at
least have to feel like they've got a
good chance because they've proven to
Kawhi Leonard that you know that what
their medical staff can do and and how
they operate it worked for him you know
beyond the basketball stuff if quite
thinking about his long-term health the
Raptors certainly can show them
something positive the best place for
Kawhi Leonard NBA wise is where like the
league
what would the league one I think people
would assume that the league would want
them like Hawaii in LA because it's a
ratings bonanza just like it was with
Golden State and when when they played
and they were successful but that's just
never been Adam Silver's mo I mean Adam
silver every time I talked to him and he
said there's other interviews as well
but just kind of craved that NFL style
parody
like that just to have you know seven
eight nine teams begin the playoffs with
a realistic chance to to win a
championship so even though the ratings
kind of tanked last year you know
because Toronto was in it and you know
get that Canadian market in the US
Nielsen ratings yeah I think the NBA
loved it I think having having a new
team win a championship for the first
time I think they did that as a net
positive so I think if all things being
equal I think the league would either
rather have Kawhi go to Toronto or go to
the Clippers which you know would would
be a good team but not a super team by
any stretch he's Chris Mannix the Sports
Illustrated senior NBA writer I
mentioned this and I'm sure nobody else
in America will today but Willie
cauley-stein to Golden State I thought
we had the great son III thought that
was a great sneaky little pick up for
them what are they getting i i i agree i
mean willie cauley-stein is he's
maddeningly inconsistent at times and
and I don't think Sacramento has any
kind of great rush to to bring him back
but for what Golden State does he kind
of fits what they try to do I mean he's
an up-tempo guy
who can shoot a little bit from the
outside from for mid-range and and and
can just be athletic out there on the
floor that's just another body that they
can pair now with Lu D and some of the
other guys they they have in that mix I
mean I still think that that this year's
kind of a I don't call a gap year but
it's it's certainly a year that you're
not anticipating the Warriors doing
anything but yeah it's a five to seven
months the recovery time for for klay
Thompson even put on the back end of
that he could be back in in early 2020
and if he can work his way into shape
by the time the playoffs come around I
don't really you can dismiss that team
as being a Finals contender that they're
certainly not what they were but but man
I mean cauley-stein you know mixing up
with Looney at the five if dream on
continues to play well if some of the
other pieces then picked up you know
kind of fit into place that they've
still got and that was the conference a
shot to win that spec office yeah and
then I saw on the mothership where
somebody was saying that they wouldn't
make the playoffs this year and I'm
thinking that they're saying they're
saying like a little bit everything on
on the mothership down there's there's
perspectives coming from all sides on
24-hour programming they're helped me
understand this because and I said it
yesterday and I think I got an answer
yesterday but the Knicks didn't offer
the the max amount of years to Kevin
Durant and I said okay they're being
prudent but I don't think the Kevin
Durant was going there if if Kyrie was
going to the Nets and they wanted
DeAndre Jordan to go to the Nets I no
matter what the Knicks are offering I
didn't think Katie was going there yeah
I think you know how it was explained to
me what because this is being spun in
like a million different directions like
like Kevin Durant wanted to go to the
neck.you
Knicks wouldn't offer max that to my
understanding that could be further from
the truth I mean in the last you know
three or four days prior to free agency
Kevin Durant had it really started to
zero in on the Nets that's that's what I
was I've been told and you know some of
that had to do with Kyrie Irving some of
that had to do with the fact the Nets
have built themselves infrastructure
there where you know the closet isn't is
an empty you know for them to step into
they've got some some good players on
that roster and the Knicks had kind of
we're basically out of consideration so
there were certainly some reluctance on
the part of James Dolan to offer a full
max to Kevin Durant but it never got to
that point you know he didn't take any
meetings with the mix he didn't from
what I understand didn't have a serious
conversation when the next about signing
there so it's sort of much ado about
nothing in a way if we were having a
conversation about you know Kevin Durant
saying I want to be a Knick and the
Knicks saying well you know we're gonna
give you you know 10 million your first
year and maxed out the years after or
something like that
then we can you know pummel the mix into
into oblivion but this it just wasn't
the case you know Kevin Durant because
everything I said was was leaning
towards the Nets pretty strongly in the
last couple of days and weeks yeah it
felt like everybody had just penciled in
we had a story and then we kept pushing
the story because that's the story we
wanted that was KD was gonna go to the
Knicks and Kyrie would join him somehow
they'd win the lottery they'd have Zion
Williamson and all of a sudden the
Knicks are back I mean that's the thing
then like only like people over like the
Knicks faithful can be just mortified
and upset by something that had an 86
percent chance of not happening which is
the you know landing the number one
overall pick I mean it just is
mind-numbing how that came to pass and
look I think the reason that the the
reason that we kind of reside it anyway
like that I thought that the Knicks
would would be a frontrunner for Durant
early on you know and during the season
was the poison you feel because there's
I I just I couldn't wrap my head around
the idea that the Knicks would trade
porzingis without at least some kind of
head nod from you know whether it's
Kyrie team or or Durant's team about you
know them coming there like they gave
away porzingis for you know quarters on
the dollar and and you had to assume
that another few was ready dropping the
goal an interview on the radio was was
goofy but I don't put any stock in what
he actually knows but they've got up
some smart people in that front office
Scott Perry has been around you know
Steve Mills at least has been around
like that to trade porzingis said that
to me is the biggest mistake they've
made in the last couple of years they
can spin it all they want me and say
porzingis wasn't gonna be there
just I just don't believe that I mean no
player I don't think any player ever dan
has turned down a max contract extension
coming off that rookie deal not the
least of which is a guy coming off an
ACL tear you're never gonna convince me
that Chris s porzingis would not sign a
five-year deal with the next is James
Dolan actually bad for the next like
does this all factor in to these free
agents at I don't I don't know if he's
their day-to-day but like what role is
he playing in all of this because he's
certainly getting all the blame that
nobody wants to play for the next yeah I
think yes the bare the brunt of it
because he's the one constant in all
this in their two decades now of
dysfunction he's the one guy that's been
there and he puts himself into the
public eye in very bizarre ways and he
has created this perception that he will
inject himself into basketball related
decisions and he will be overly involved
in the process moreover I think there
are two types of owners that that
players want to be around they want to
be around us Palmer because of the
positive energy that he kind of exudes
and and how much money that we know he
pours into the franchise or they want to
be involved with guys behind the scenes
like I mean how many people in the NBA
could have picked your hole out of a
lineup for the last two decades I mean I
covered the league and I don't think I
could like it but Peter Holt was the
type of guy in San Antonio that just you
know empowered RC Buford empowered Gregg
Popovich and then get out of the way and
you know don't lay Cup and Golden State
was a little more front and center to a
degree but he never stepped on Bob Myers
or for Steve Kerr I mean James Golan
just seems like he's putting his stamp
on whether it's putting his own guy
Steve mills in charge of basketball
operations or involving himself
personally and stuff I mean that's the
kind of thing that if you're looking for
something I could tip the scale that's
it I mean when James Dolan operates like
that
that can tip the scale one way or the
other why do you think Golden State is
retiring Kevin Durant's Jersey
I assume they're retiring Brian
Cardinals Jersey right back in the day I
mean that I mean it's a PR move here it
is you can kind of see him a guy was a
two-time Finals MVP there I mean Robin
ship I mean they don't win without Kevin
Durant those two championships as simple
as that they do dollars Jersey good
return I don't know that's like a
slippery slope right like you start to
you start to wonder like the guys that
were part of these championships for a
number of years I mean you're gonna
retire Steph you're in retire clay
draymond I assume if he finds one more
contract may be retired his number but
your your fact getting into like Celtics
territory whether it's not put names up
there like like let's get off and spin
like but you know know step up there
instead of his number at some point
thank you Chris we appreciate your time
as always
you got Dan that's Chris Mannix senior
NBA writer Sports Illustrated for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]